all right guys
bang bang rachel is back for round two
what's going on how are you
hey thank you for having me absolutely
uh i feel like you have a crazy crazy
life to begin with and now
you've got uh corona you have a
new baby you have a husband who is a
firefighter
who i'm sure is doing all kinds of
awesome cool crazy things
what has been going on in your life over
the last couple of months
like a really cool time to have a baby
with the first responder in brooklyn
like around may
i was just like really feeling that uh
yeah it was crazy but i will say there's
a few benefits to a covid birth
um even though there are no commercials
for cope at birth there are a few
benefits like
no fear of missing out um no one wanted
guests all you have to say is sorry
we're trying not to kill her
so there were a couple perks um
but it was strange it was definitely
strange to be married to a firefighter
during that time
i mean i get a kick out of being married
to a fireman usually it's just something
i can like [ __ ] out at airports and try
to get upgrades with
you know but it definitely got a little
bit real around corona that's what i'm
like oh this isn't
as fun loving a time as it was before
what exactly was going on so let's talk
let's talk about the baby first
you obviously were pregnant before
corona happened then you have a child uh
during this whole thing were you nervous
were you scared
were you excited because then you didn't
have to deal with people like what were
you feeling going through i mean i was
definitely scared i was
i'm not one of those women that is
pumped up about
pregnancy to begin with so uh
that was a little tough um i mean i
first of all i hadn't told people in the
beginning because i had recently sold
this pilot to fox based on my
life and being married to an fdny
firefighter and
and uh just kind of my life with my
jewish liberal
aggressively liberal parents that would
have preferred me marrying like a
nigerian lesbian or something
and uh and now my new life of like
staten island dinner dances
and everyone's name is like gina and uh
so i sold a pilot about that and i was
really excited um then i got pregnant
and i was like wait this
is gonna shoot in march when i'll be
like an actual whale like i won't be
able to hold
any laundry basket that can cover it um
and my character wouldn't hold laundry
baskets anyway
uh my character which is me but um
so i was kind of like [ __ ] [ __ ] that's
not good timing and then i was
just covering it i was just dressing
like bea arthur
uh a lot of oversized paula pound stone
blazers
um and then cove it happened
and i was like oh it was never gonna
even shoot in march anyway
so it was a set of uh problems i never
expected to have
you know because he's i guess my worst
fear being when i was being pregnant was
that i would kind of like
be isolated and dependent and then i was
but for completely different reasons
so um you know she's healthy
and as a mother i start all my sentences
that way by the way now i just go as a
mother
and then i just pass out drunk after
that but uh
so i'm just i'm grateful for that but no
i was not
into it all my friends wanted me to like
have a home birth i was like
[ __ ] that i want like that like this
lady was like what are the words that
you want surrounding your birth like
and i was like i don't know like i don't
have a vision i just want like doctors
and i don't know sterile
i guess that would be a good word around
my birth vanity
drugs i just wanted to be crunching on
drugs
and a sterile hospital environment and
it was hard to find that
in covid in new york so we moved up to
um
to a hospital up to westchester and uh
it was yeah it was weird i had
gestational diabetes so
i had to like prick myself five times a
day because the hospital couldn't do
any i mean i had to do all virtual
appointments they couldn't do any like
diabetic
in-person checks for a few months we
couldn't do a sonogram so there was like
a lot of crazy stuff
uh but then she turned out pretty good i
i feel like going through this
is uh it kind of removes a lot of the
[ __ ] of like the
kind of i'll call it like medical
theater like i feel like there's a lot
of just people trying to
make people feel good and happy and
safe during a lot of this but like the
actual process i've got a friend right
now that's pregnant and
uh for the longest time like she would
go to the doctor but like
um her significant other couldn't go
with her right and so like there's all
these things where like
it's kind of weird where you don't have
like the emotional support but at the
same time like
i don't know 50 different visits gets
cut down to like the 20 essential ones
yeah so it's like kind of this like
really weird like is that a positive or
is that a negative i'm not really
sure but it seems to have worked out
there are odd benefits to it for sure
and and the time where you'd be at home
nesting we were doing that
you know anyway and and not feeling like
we were
missing out on everything so there were
some weird
um benefits for sure and it was just
like in the beginning
remember in march when like first of all
when i found out i was in florida
on the road so everybody at home was
pissed that i was in florida
and everybody in florida was pissed
because i cancelled my shows halfway
through the weekend
and then you feel terrible as a comic
ever doing that because you're letting
the staff down
and if i wasn't pregnant i would have
just kept performing but
um i was like it'd be really awkward if
i you know killed my baby at like
captain
bryan's in florida comedy club it would
just be a really
it wouldn't be a good look you know but
fl but florida was open
they were chilling they would have let
you keep they were oh yeah it was
bustling i mean the shows were full i
don't know and it wasn't even because of
me they were just
yeah they that was around the time where
you couldn't get a loaf of bread or like
toilet paper in brooklyn
but uh florida i would just like mention
the lady at the hotel we were staying at
she was like blinking me like what just
this weird lobotomized blank
like what karoni everything's fine
so i uh in maybe july
i went to florida to see somebody
uh it was an important thing right and
when i went uh i felt like there was uh
two very different worlds like literally
new york everyone's walking around with
the masks like you know
very serious uh this is put like now
there's toilet paper at the grocery
store like so
things are kind of like getting a little
normal but still very serious
in florida they're they were chilling
like
i don't know if there was ever a period
where they weren't chilling but they
were just hanging out there was no
problem whatsoever
like looking at people if you wore a
mask you were weird
yes for sure definitely and so i had to
i was walking around in that in march
when it was like remember when tom we
found out tom hanks had it and like a
couple guys from the golden state
warriors and everybody was like oh then
we can get it too
since we have so much in common it's
very strange remember how that made it
real for everyone
like tom hanks i'm next obviously
uh since we have all the same friends
but that was strange i know and then i
had my mother on the phone like
you know just yelling at me like how can
you do this with cope at 19 and like
nobody says the 19 anymore my mom is
still saying the 19.
um and i'm like where did she live again
my mom lives in maryland
and yeah i mean she didn't even need the
baby until like four months
they were just they had bags over their
heads for like four months they were
like in a hefty plastic bag
so all right so all this is going on
you eventually have the child uh
meanwhile
uh we go through covid which i have no
clue what firemen were doing
during covet but i wouldn't want to be a
fireman or a police officer during any
of that
and then we get the protest and then we
get
like riots i guess i i don't know there
was like some protest some riot
sometimes they were mixed sometimes they
weren't it's funny my my family called
him protest and his family called him
riots it was amazing like
my mom was like are you gonna join any
of the protests and his family
watch out for the riots
it's funny yeah they uh thank god there
was no
um to fund the fire department that
would have been awkward
but um i i fee i feel like uh firemen
are kind of
safe like no one ever like goes at the
fire department because they realize
like when the fire starts you want
somebody to show up to put it out
yeah i mean there's definitely like
there's definitely moments when
like if i'm having an argument with him
on the street when he's in his uniform
uh that i wouldn't mind walking by a
protest of people
you know against him but um there's
gotta be some cop
who's like his wife is just like yeah
yell at him for me today thank you
you know but no everybody gets around i
mean everybody likes firemen and what's
not to like about
i mean you know the scene could be what
it is but they tend to be pretty hot
i like being a firewire or badge banger
that's what i prefer to call wait
what are they called firewife is one of
the terms i tried to get started but it
couldn't really get much traction
okay um so now i just identify as a
badge banker
[Laughter]
so what was he doing this entire time
well okay so
he was uh i realized how as i watch you
try to keep up with what i'm saying i
realize i am quite manic
um well if it makes you feel any better
i feel like we're talking about a person
who uh like kind of exists kind of
doesn't because every time
the last time you came on in this time
we don't say his name we don't say what
he does we just say firemen and then you
you just rattle off a bunch of funny
stories
i'll make him pass by at some point he
saw you on
cnn or something so he was very
impressed i think it was cnn you were on
cnn right
good i tricked him yes in finance in a
very in an impressive looking suit
uh that suit was from kohl's let's not
call it let's not call it
expensive
so yeah so he totally knows who you are
and you're on all his uh
crypto apps so i'll make him come
through
if anyone didn't listen to the first
episode uh rachel's husband
is a fire chief if i remember correctly
he's a he's a fire captain but he just
passes cheap test so he will be a chief
okay and he is a uh secret bitcoiner
or uh is he an outed bitcoiner he's
outed
outed and my favorite part of the last
episode was rachel told a story where
other people from the fire department
come over and they just yell things
either about
the government bitcoin or lock her up
and then
i said that sounds about like every
bitcoin or on
twitter oh yeah lock her up
but uh no it's a lot yeah there's always
and they all scream about the founding
fathers when they're drunk
there's a lot of founding fathering um
and then they come home with like
conspiracy theories like he goes to the
firehouse
and he comes back and he'll come back
like vinnie said they legit
went to the moon i'm like no they did
like vinnie knows nothing and don't
believe anything
after someone says legit please stop
listening
but yeah they come home because they
have access to his brain for like
more of the week than i do so i can only
undo so much
there's a lot of pamphlets going around
what's the craziest conspiracy theory
that you've heard
this wasn't peed specifically but um
i was at this dinner dance on the staten
island dinner dinner i'm always the only
jew too i'm just wait
what it was a dinner dance what are
these dinner dances
where you go with your man and then it's
like they
he just deposits me at like some shrimp
station you know with these
good fellas extras and i uh
and then they do it's like fdny dances
and so
i do you dance with him or do the
firemen dance with each other
no we yeah i dance with him but that
would be great i would watch a couple of
greased firemen dancing with each other
um i'd prefer them greased but yeah no
we
we dance with each other there's just
like food and you know a lot of acrylics
you know with with star like stars and
stripes on them
and [ __ ] and uh yeah that's the world
basically and so
um they're either they're usually like
gina vinnie um
what are the other names there's like
four names you know maybe
colleen um and they're all are they all
like neighbors
yeah everybody knows each other and they
usually tell me when they know another
jew like one of the
other chiefs was like i met a jew a very
nice lady
very nice lady
yum kapoor like they'll just say one jew
thing they've heard of
it's a lot does it buy street crud
no i mean when people like drop that one
jew thing it's
it's alarming yeah it's like i think
they don't see anything but a jew and
they're talking to me they're just like
they just see like a giant j i'm just
like i'm talking to a jew i'm talking to
and shoot like
they just see like little horns or wrote
i don't know floating
the star of david or some [ __ ] it's
strange because i
don't even i'm not even religious but
they just hear my name and they're like
jew i know a jew
you know so anyway so he leaves me at
some table and this guy comes up and he
was like you gotta come with me and my
wife
the epcot and then he goes that's the
real japan and epcot
that's japan because people think you
gotta spend all his cash
and fly all the way to japan but it's a
[ __ ] scam
he referred to traveling the world as a
scam and epcot is reality somehow
to be fair to some people he's not wrong
no people believe it's japan they think
it's i mean we went
we did go yeah did you go with him or by
yourselves
we went with another fireman couple
actually yeah we went to epcot and then
you know he him too he was like so you
don't even have to go because it's you
it's you i mean
there's there's too many things to go
there all right let's talk about stand
up there's
so much going on uh you don't know the
story yet
but uh maybe in like april i got an
email from somebody and they were like
hey
uh i need you to come on this live
stream this is what everyone was like
figuring out like what is zoom
and they were like oh i have a like i
have a camera on my laptop i didn't know
i had that and
there's microphones and they were trying
to figure it all out and this guy was
like
uh we're having a virtual event this was
the first virtual event that i was gonna
participate in i was like what is that
he goes we're gonna take the real event
we're gonna put it online
i was like this is gonna be a disaster
and so he's
he said uh and after you are gonna be
these two comedians i don't remember
their names
they weren't somebody that i'd uh
recognize and
uh it was the first time that i saw how
hard it was gonna be for comedians
to basically talk into their laptop
with no fan reactions or audience
reactions
and just hope that it's going well like
it was yeah it's not
it's not a virtual sport you know
so talk a little bit just about like
what you have you been doing
from a comedy side and then like now as
things are opening up kind of what's the
plan
um i mean stand up has taken a massive
massive hit
so it's just like we can't i mean
i took for granted the money i could
make in a weekend
especially if if you're headlining you
know what the features
now i'm sorry it's the opposite the
people that are featuring
opening okay uh when i used to open you
barely cover your travel it's just the
way you
you build up and try to um
you know build a fan base basically uh
so those the people that are featuring
are the most screwed and um the openers
and
and i was there and you're barely making
ends meet anyways you sell
a cd or something like that like online
album or something to try to make extra
cash on top of what you're making
some headliners will cover your you know
hotel or travel
um and i always did that if anybody was
featuring for me but now we're making
you know i mean less than a third or i
mean
maybe a fifth of what we're making
because we can't uh
they all want if they are opening a club
it's gonna be a third of capacity
and then um or they're doing it outside
and performing in like fields
and fire escapes it's not okay i i did
this show in somebody's backyard
recently and there was like some people
outside
in brooklyn and they were like don't
talk whatever you do before i got on
stage you can call it somebody goes
listen whatever you do don't talk to the
lady in blue hair she's
been screaming about the patriarchy and
she's really drunk
and i was like can you just like kick
her out and they were like no it's
her yard and i was like okay fair but
that's that in a nutshell
where we're at like i had such arrogance
as a comic because
we've always you since i started
headlining you just you get work because
people go to comedy clubs and it's been
a
somewhat successful business at least if
you can't make your money and
if you don't get this pilot picked up
for this writing job or whatever you
always have stand up because you could
just jump on stage
you don't need anybody else you don't
need like i that's why i always feel
sorry for people in bands because
such a skill i don't have and i'm they
don't need me to feel sorry for them i
mean i also envy them
but i'm like they have to wait on like
four other guys and you know and a drum
set
the guitar and like equipment we can
just go on and do stand up and it's the
best you get to write it you get to
you control so many aspects of it it's a
very
independent thing you know and you can
tweak your act to fit all these factors
you know
how old how young how pc how
are they trump people are they super
liberal or you know whatever so
um i just always made money doing it no
matter what i was waiting on and there's
been plenty of like heartbreak
with you know with those like pilots or
tv things or whatever
um but i took it for granted because i
just couldn't imagine
a scenario that would destroy it
like that you know so i mean couldn't
work at all for months and i'd never
gone that long without doing stand up
since i started stand up when i was like
20 21 i haven't gone like
uh you know a week or two without doing
stand up so
you get the most was probably my
honeymoon which was like two weeks yeah
do you get rusty you i forgot like
my material like things that i've i've
done for years it was crazy like stuff
that
this is like the joke i do when i'm
bombing and i'm kind of embarrassed and
hope a comic's not in the room to see it
but it's like that easy bit i know will
do well and i grab it when i'm having a
tough set like those bits i forgot it
was so strange i was like
people always ask you they go how do you
remember it all and i'm always like it's
not a thing you just
they're your stories you know them but
you forget it if you don't do it for
months you forget
how it go i was just on stage like
mixing up a
setup and a punch you're just lost you
know so
now i that's why i'm going up at all
these free places in between or any
comedy club that's having a show on
their patio just because i want to
remember how to do it for when i am
headlining um
in a local field or you know some sort
of heated tent
they're coming they're coming what are
you what are you hearing from like the
comedy clubs themselves in terms of
i'm assuming one they're struggling just
like every small business it's got a
physical location
but to uh have they been able to do
certain things to maybe kind of get some
kind of revenue when they were shut down
or how do they look at uh kind of moving
forward a lot of them are closing some
of my favorite clubs in the world
my favorite clubs in austin this club
cap city
uh that i've played for years and
they're just like it's just an
awesome family-owned cool place and um
they shut down i was like no way a lot
of them are shutting down
or they're going to have to shut down
it's impending
and uh in new york what the way i feel
is
it's very low here right now covet is
really low so if they're opening
restaurants
um we should open comedy clubs so that
they don't all
fall apart you know i understand when it
was high why we had to close them
but now if they're gonna slowly open up
restaurants and it is under one percent
in new york i would like then open up
comedy clubs because people are dining
they're last take their masks off when
they're dining and you know see how it
goes
if it doesn't go well then close them
back up again but are they not opening a
laugh right now
uh no they're not um why is that like
they just kind of like nightclubs they
have it's some sort of idea about the
comic
i don't know their face being exposed or
something i mean cuomo
is the one who doesn't want to open it
and and schumer
the senator chuck schumer has this bill
like save our stages that he's trying to
push through
to open up to open up comedy again so
i'm really hoping that that
bill goes through for now especially
because i feel like people need it and
obviously we need it to to live and we
don't want all our favorite clubs and
places to shut down but um
while we can i say like let's get some
in and see how it goes you know if
you're opening up restaurants it's
essentially the same thing
people have their masks off when they're
inside of restaurants so it's like
why can't the one comedian have their
mask off and just perform
at a third of capacity or however
they're opening up so i feel like it's
worth trying
i i went and uh i've gotten two haircuts
last month which is like more than i got
the whole year because i basically just
you know
let it let it loose and say whatever
during corona uh and both times they've
got like the temperature gun
and each time that they like shoot you
with this temperature gun i'm like first
of all how do i know that you're taking
my temperature and you're not like
somehow putting some [ __ ] in my brain or
you know whatever like a
true libertarian that's something my
husband would say no one cares
no one's putting a chip in you oh my god
that was that's the kind of [ __ ] he says
all the time
how do i know they're not like actually
reading my thoughts
i feel like me and your husband would
get along really
no so like they got this temperature gun
thing but and like that's fine whatever
like i get it you want to check the
temperature i don't know if necessarily
you know whether
uh i have coveted or not based on this
temperature check thing but somebody
said somewhere that they do so fine
but then you go you sit down they're
gonna cut your hair and she's like leave
your mask on
i was like okay uh that's gonna be weird
but like sure we'll give this a shot
starts cutting and then at one point
she's like can you take it off of your
ear
but like hold it over your mouth still
and i was like what is going on here
they have the distinctions get a little
confusing
they have like plexiglas but it's not
like fully encapsulating like the
plexiglas basically just goes to like
where the person sitting down shoulder
is it's like does the virus like not go
under
the plexiglass or around it
this is very weird it is very confusing
a lot of like the smaller distinctions
you know and i i think some of it is
probably like theater just like airport
security is you know
but like i don't know it's confusing but
then i get i mean
i guess i do think that like some
something's gotta help i mean i have no
information though with formal education
i should point out
my favorite thing to say is uh i'm not a
scientist and i literally have no clue
what's true anymore
like i have no clue right it's just like
there's like some common sense things
and i'm like okay i'm just gonna put my
mask on and just like go
go do whatever they tell me fine like
i'll play this game uh yeah i mean it
can't i guess it can't hurt
you know i mean i do think that like
some amount of med
you know we got to take some measures
right and then see how it goes but i do
think it's insane to say
just like restaurants can open but
comedy clubs can
and it's unnecessarily punishing just
give it a shot you know
that's all i i feel strongly about that
you know and i hope that
schumer bill goes through i think
personally i think cuomo's taking it too
far with that
there's a guy who owns a restaurant down
the street uh from me
and i walked by him every day and he was
like my uh barometer
for uh for how the small business
reaction to all this was
so uh when they first opened up he was
you know basically bitching and
complaining that
uh he had to build something in the
street so they could have seating but he
did it
and then at one point he uh he like i'm
walking by and he like got really
animated he started dropping the f-bomb
like and i was like
this is not how this guy normally acts
and i was like what's up man and he's
like you're telling me they can go get a
massage and get their nails done but you
can't go inside my restaurant and he was
freaking out
and i was like look man you're talking
the wrong guy
i'm not going to get a massage i'm not
getting my nails done but i'll come eat
at your restaurant
that's all i got for you now i mean some
of the yeah
some of it is crazy and i feel like i i
don't know i hope that bill goes through
because i feel like it you know
especially the places where it's super
low
we have to like find some model to open
up again you know
so what are other comedians doing over
the last couple of months are is anyone
practicing are they getting better or is
everyone just like
[ __ ] it no we just started like
performing outside in new york like
comedy clubs are having patio shows and
stuff like that i had shows and like
you know outside venues we can do that
still while it's warm so we're
performing locally and doing that um as
much as we can
and seeing each other and i i don't know
if we're getting better but we're
starting out to get as
awful it's getting a lot it's definitely
i'll say this i i definitely feel
comfortable and i can do my hour now i
can headline again and i'm
you know so i don't know if i'm writing
a whole new one
you know but practicing on patios but um
with blue-haired ladies screaming about
the patriarchy but
i do know that uh i'm not i don't think
i'm getting worse again so and i think
people need it like the crowds have been
really good
i mean i will say that they haven't been
as large as we'd like them to be
um we're not making the living that
we're making at all but
you know the people are coming out and
it feels good to do stand up right now
you know people are hurting absolutely
uh
when is your night your next one this is
going to get published on tuesday you've
got one on wednesday
so my next one is on uh september 30th
at the stress factory in new jersey and
it's outside kind of like heated uh
kind of thing and they'll be mozzarella
sticks and good jokes
jokes i don't know that's why i go
places for the mozzarella sticks and the
beer
i always say that before what city what
city is this
uh this is in hold on i have to check
isn't that sad
um the stress factor is new brunswick
new brunswick all right the stress
factor it's called the stress
factory so if you want to get tickets
you go to new
brunswick.stressfactory.com
and then you can get tickets to see me
at 7 30 and it's my birthday so
people oh and it's your birthday yeah oh
nice
all right everyone go buy tickets duh
no-brainer i know a bunch of you live in
new jersey
go do it uh what's going on with uh the
pilot and
with um the television
uh netflix all the things that everyone
thinks comedians sit around and do all
day
i mean all i watch personally in terms
of watching is
is murder i can't get enough true crime
i don't know what that says about me but
i can't go to sleep until i've seen like
uh
forensic files and a wives with knives
for some reason
like my husband handled pandemic anxiety
you know having a baby and global
pandemic anxiety by like
he's a researcher so he just over
researches everything
and um i'm the opposite like we got a
car recently and i would come home and
he would just like kept
like having those car videos playing
with like cars on different terrain
and stuff it was just so boring i
couldn't weep and he was always just
like what do you think of this you know
like i know
nothing he could bring home like a ford
dart and i'd be like oh
so i guess it comes from money you know
like i don't give a [ __ ]
i just was like how about the kind of
car where you can put your cell phone
and it just charges it you know like you
could just balance it there he's like i
can't
buy an suv based on whether it can
charge my cell phone in a certain way
and i was like that's all i cared about
but he over researches everything so he
dealt with his pandemic fear
by just watching a lot of like diaper
hacks
and like you know jackson's tummy time
tips like baby jackson's tummy time
that's what he did i would get into bed
and not me my fireman husband would lay
there in his uniform watching
like some like one of those you know
what i mean those youtube [ __ ] that are
like
so anyway with my first kid jackson we
were able to do sleep socks
and truman didn't take as well to it
runner was really amazing with sleep
socks so every baby's different i'm like
please stop please stop
listen i got i got to defend him here's
the thing that people don't understand
so i'm watching a friend of mine go
through this right now he's having his
first kid
guys don't know anything about anything
like we
we all went uh somewhere for a weekend
and we were all staying in the kitchen
and i like you know i got real confident
and i was like
all right i'm gonna ask some questions
here like i'm gonna get a little bit of
education
and as soon as i start asking questions
like my wife is like staring
across the kitchen at me like ready to
murder me and i was just like
so like uh you know like that cord uh
what's up with the cord thing like you
know they like cut it and she
you know they're like looking like what
do you mean and by the way the guy who's
having the kid is getting the education
at the same time like he doesn't know
any of this
and so it's like i don't think people
understand
like you're going from zero to having to
be educated
it's not like it's not like oh i kind of
sort of know some of this stuff and like
now i just gotta learn the details
it's like i've never even heard of that
topic before now let me go
get educated and be ready for this human
to like be under my
control that is true and guys have no
idea they have some strange impulses he
was like can i put the baby in a swing
at the park i'm like no she's four
months old you can't just put her on a
swing she doesn't have
like were you just gonna do that were
you just gonna drop a four-month-old on
a swing and like see what happened
but all that being said i will say i am
kind of
like worthless too i didn't read any
books you know i just wanted to watch
uh serial killer documentaries when i
was pregnant so um we had a baby nurse
and she told me everything
you know i mean she just explained
everything and
and i was sitting on her bed at one
point after we had the baby and it was
like a perfectly made bed because she
just
does everything in that perfect little
baby nurse way like i'm like i'll never
be able to replicate this when this
woman is gone
and all of a sudden she looked at me and
she was like oh my god you're bleeding
and i was like i've gotten through covet
i've gone through everything
what the [ __ ] now and i looked down and
i realized that i had um smeared my
protein bar
all over the bed of this lovely woman
who's like helping me care for my
newborn baby
and there was just like fudge and like
cranberry from a protein bar and i was
like i am a pig
how can i keep a human alive
so that was kind of my experience i'm
not like a normal
mother you know and i can tell that but
if you start every sentence with as a
mother
as a mother yeah and then you just strip
protein bar all over the baby nurses
what's the craziest thing you've blamed
on being a mother
like what's the thing that you've like
just like ah no worries i'm a mother
i mean anything i'll have like a smear
of jaeger on my cheek and i'm like i'm
sorry mom
you know how like all those moms they
always have like they always have like
instagram headings like boxed one is my
juice box or whatever you know so
i kind of try to get in on that like
i'll check my one with my whining or
whatever
um and so i usually try to do that but
with like
you know jager or harder flicker you
know
i'm like 10 shots of whiskey paulina's
been showing me these uh tick tocks
there's like a
like a mom tick tock uh thing and
uh they're all different moms all over
the country and they like basically
create content for each other
on tick tock where their kids are and
i'm sure the kids aren't excited that
their moms are on the same platform or
whatever
interesting but they're just like you
know when my when uh the baby goes to
bed and literally every video is the
same they're just
chugging liquor and i'm like okay
and so hearing you talk about jager i'm
like there is a reoccurring theme here
yeah but with them it's usually just
like a glass of rose or something
somehow it feels acceptable
um but my husband doesn't drink anymore
so i'm not as worthless as i used to he
quit drinking a couple years ago so now
it's more
it's more like just falling asleep
eating just doing a lot of feeding
in bed and passing out that's how i numb
myself
what's been the biggest surprise since
you had a kid
um honestly you know i thought i had a
lot of fear about it because i was like
what if i don't connect to her
especially because
i'm an over-sharer like i tell i'll tell
anybody anything
i have i hang out for like five minutes
and i'm just like so i still have some
anger at my dad but
i'm feeling better about it you know so
i was like what if i don't connect to
her because i'll tell people
i was like i'll be that woman at a
barbecue like isn't it weird that i
don't love her
like i'll have one corona and just start
telling people
and i'm like that'll be worse than not
loving her i won't be able to not tell
people and it won't be cool
so thank god i like i think i had so
much anxiety about it and like fear
and focused on all the potential
catastrophic things happening
on top of what was happening you know in
the world that i didn't consider
all the good and fun parts so it was
like pleasantly surprising
you know and i was like i loved her
right away which makes me a hero i think
right sorry my husband just walked in
and out of trouble
so obviously probably because he heard
you talking about the fact that
you were worried about not loving your
daughter
well i was like it is a thing you hear
about that women don't connect
that happens it doesn't mean they don't
eventually love in them
in beginning sometimes women have
postpartum or they have some
issue and they don't like bond is as
early a lot of women will say that they
don't bond right away or something and
then they slowly do usually i don't know
anybody that still doesn't love their
kids
but yeah that's the 15 year old that's
the one
we just don't get we just don't really
hit it off
i mean sometimes there is a hole in the
team you know you'll see three kids and
you're like they definitely love that
one
the most you know not the other one so
but luckily we only have one kid and
uh yeah loved her right away i think
because i had so much nerves about it
that i was just so pleasantly surprised
and she's very cute so i'm i'm pretty
into it
it's fun it's like a movie like it just
she's entertains us she does silly
little things all the time
she's great yeah i i feel like uh you
guys seem to have like
done pretty well with this like
coronavirus
uh protest riots baby like
still alive you have a car
it charges your phone like there's
progress going on in your house
he's an amazing dad like does everything
everything does he have does he have the
uh front backpack
yes he has the carrier thing yeah he's
got all of that
and he's obsessed like jumps up every
time she cries when i was pregnant
he was like somewhat uh worthless like
we got on uh when i was in florida he
was with me
and then we went back to the airport
after we had to fly and it was like
you know may 15 whatever whenever uh the
golden state warriors got
so and then he boarded the plane
without me i went to get a water i was
seven months [ __ ] pregnant
he boards the plane without me
environment maybe he thought you were on
the plane
no he thought i went to get a water and
i was taking too long and i got on the
plane i'm like what the [ __ ]
and he was like i just thought i'd like
get situated i'm like
there's nobody even on this plane there
was like a third of the people were even
on the plane
you thought you'd get yourself situated
i was like what the [ __ ] were you
thinking but he's
firemen because they're first responders
and maybe other first responders too
they're like
under reactors in those situations it's
like having an argument with like the
9-1-1 operator you know when you
whenever you hear those tapes and you're
like that poor woman like
won't she at least put some warmth in
her voice like i know she can't say
certain stuff but just be like
don't we'll be right there they're
always like all right ma'am
okay you know that's what that's what
it's like with him i'm like
where the [ __ ] were you he's like yeah
just thought he gets situated i'm like
do not understand
how insanely awful that is he's like
yeah i guess i just figured you'd be on
your way and i'm like
no so he was that he was that
he he may have just been checking the
plane for coping
making sure that he got it off before
you got there
i mean it was yeah it was astonishing
but then
i think you know what but the baby i
mean also
maybe it's something about a girl i
don't know i mean
he's he'll do everything for her yeah
yeah that's great we'll do it all so
he's definitely very into being a dad um
i feel like
that is the one thing that every guy
talks about is like
it's a rite of passage you get little
carrier things strap it on your chest
you walk down the street
little babies bopping around you can't
put it in a swing we i now know that
that's i'm glad that he uh he figured
that out before uh i ever have a kid so
i know that
uh i gotta ask you i have not seen it
yet but i've had multiple people tell me
the movie
uh king of staten island i think it's
called is that the one
it's about uh ryan p davidson pete's
david pete davidson's dad died in 9 11
and so it's it's about like what his
life kind of it's sort of he's not a
comedian in the movie but it's about his
his life and his family you know some
things are changed but
did you guys watch it yeah i watched it
separately from him but it's
it's really good it's excellent is that
what the
and bill burns is a good friend of mine
and a comedian and he's amazing
and super talented and is incredible in
it
yeah i went on billboard's podcast and
he was screaming about the federal
reserve for like half the time
to the point where i thought he was
going to run for president he's always
equally equally furious about like it
could be
he's super educated though that's that's
the scariest part is a comedian
who's educated and mad like i was i was
very impressed with how much he knew
but he was very mad and i was i was
there for it i loved it
uh but is that is that what the fdny
culture is like in that movie
yeah i mean a lot of it is very accurate
i mean this is also like
a while ago but you know it's definitely
it's definitely very active i mean
there's a there's a subculture to the
fire department and they understand
each other in a way nobody else does
it's a lot like comics in a way except
you know again they save people's lives
and we're narcissists but uh
they i mean there's they work off
adrenaline
you know their highs are really high and
then the downtime is like
awesome you know so and the lows are
very low and very scary so it's like
there's this and there's this language
they speak that nobody else speaks like
when we hang out at the table at the
comedy cellar
this this club that we it's kind of my
home club when i'm in new york and i
miss being there so much now we just sit
at that table and like slam wings and
our dumb faces and just say unspeakable
things to each other you know
and then a comedian will come up with
this girlfriend or
or a female comic will come up with her
boyfriend or whatever and
the comics get annoyed they're like oh
someone's had to bring up
and we'll call them a civilian we'll be
like oh they had to bring us a billion
you know
because we can't speak the way we speak
because we're just disgusting we're
animals so we just say like crazy
nonsense that other people are called by
environment are the same
are people gonna get offended just we
don't feel like we could talk as
comfortably
you know with non-comics i think that's
how a lot of comedians feel and like
also people that aren't comedians
they'll sort of
come and try to be on in a certain way
or
be like you sh i should be a comedian
you should put that in your skit you
should put this in your scout we're
crazy
you've got to come to my job you get
that a lot like you should come to where
i work and i'm like
i don't really need to go to like
the store you work at in tampa like i
have a good idea of what happens there
i'll get material i think on my own but
people do that and so comics get like
weird they don't want
yeah they just want to be comedians and
not think about it yeah i think it's
kevin hart's got a piece where he's like
people come up to him and they're like
hey man be funny
and he's like what the [ __ ] like and
like yeah come on let's go like tell me
a joke and he's just like
this isn't how this works like and he
has this whole thing about just like
people expect comedians to be funny 100
of the time no matter where they are
at all like literally just walk up to
you while you're eating dinner and be
like rachel come on tell me a joke like
that's your job yeah they don't
understand you have like other aspects
to your
i mean a lot there are a lot of people
that do and they're really lovely but a
lot of times people from the audience
right after the show will sort of expect
you to be
funny or they'll come up and kind of nag
you like give you [ __ ] and think like
that's how you like to be talked to
or something so it's weird and
environment is the same kind of thing
when i stopped by the firehouse like i
feel like the
chemical change in the room when i walk
into that firehouse kitchen because
and i want to be like no i'm an animal
too like you can keep saying the
disgusting things you were just saying
she hear my friends we're like 10 times
worse but there's some weird
similarities
you know have you walked into the
firehouse yet and just roasted a bunch
of them
like i feel like that immediately puts
you on even playing field just walk in
one day
and just the worst things that you would
say to your comedian friends
just go down the line every single
fireman and my guess is that not only
will they not be mad
they'll just come right back and then
your husband will have to go hey guys
come on
i mean i can't i wouldn't do that
because they don't know me like that but
i'll
so i wouldn't i don't know them to [ __ ]
with them like that you know what i mean
but i will
he's what's called a bouncing captain so
he goes to different firehouses so he
might be at one firehouse this week and
another firehouse next week and he's the
boss
so the guys are like you know nervous
around so it's fun to drop in because
they don't know that i'm his wife in the
beginning
so there's one firehouse where they all
stand outside and they
like the younger guys there's like a
little bit of a separation you know
between the boss like he wouldn't go out
with them
or whatever so he'll be up in his office
uh smoking a cigar or
watching newborn or something and um
i'll walk up outside
and then like so the young guys they
stand outside
with dog treats so that if a cute girl
comes by with a dog they can give it to
her you know so
it was like halloween and i walked up
kind of slowly
and um one of the guys did that thing
where he looks back at the other guy and
tells him there's an ass worth reviewing
as you're passing they go like
you know and they think we don't know
this like this is the most simple
obvious eye contact and i was spirit
cluttered that i had an ass worth you're
doing but
they just do this he looks back to his
friends and then so they all look and so
then i just kind of slowed down
and it was like you know halloween so
there's a lot of drugs in the street so
i was like
it's really scary out there boys first
of all thank you for your service
i think i could come in for a little bit
and take cover just a lot of douchebags
out there and i'm frightened
you know and they just did not expect
that
so one of the guys was like yeah sure
come on in uh we get some snacks in the
kitchen uh
yeah absolutely come in you know so i
walk in i'm like
is captain brandon here by any chance
and they just like turn [ __ ] white
you know
and then he calls him on the little
rocky like
he goes boss your boss is here and so
pete comes down he wouldn't give a [ __ ]
first of all he's not jealous he'll just
hand me to anybody that asks for me
just be like have her back within a week
or so but uh
and another time i went by the firehouse
and this was fun
so sometimes i'll bring buy food like
you know wings from the comedy seller or
whatever
and a lot of them are really uh
attractive
um so i'll look for any excuse to just
like pop in
i beat something you know so i come by
and i have a box
they get very suspicious of outside food
right because people bring probably like
weird
jacked up gangrenous things like just
some old lady that brings them some
strange
[ __ ] and they may get a chip a chip may
get implanted in their brains if they
eat the
cookies exactly all right
so you so you bring up the box so
they're a suspicious group in general so
i come by
with this box and these cookies i bought
um
and they had a like a tie around them
and i go to one of the guys don't worry
i bought these
you know they're not i didn't bring them
from my home and then uh they don't know
i'm you know pete's wife and i go
and they're all tied up you can see i
just got them from the place and the guy
was like you like to be tied up
so then so one of the other guys
happens to know because he used to work
at a different firehouse but i'm pete's
wife he's like hey come here buddy he's
like what do you like to be dead
he thinks of just some neighborhood [ __ ]
that you know has the hots for firemen
to come by with cookies one of the guys
is like hey let me talk to you for a
second buddy you kind of take some on a
walk around the rig and the guy
came back just shook you know it was so
fun to [ __ ] with them
and i told pete on the way home and he's
like oh he'll have a nickname forever
for that incident you know but he
doesn't give a [ __ ]
again he'll just hand me right off it
it's literally like the army
like you just the the culture is so
different
and i feel like you get the best of both
worlds
which is like you get to participate in
the community uh comedian's world
and then you get to go and you know
exactly the buttons to push in the
fireman world and they have
like it's unfair of you to walk in there
to these
unsuspecting suspects and just
destroy them and then and then you have
like the trump card
oh yeah by the way can i see the boss
i know it's so it's the best i love it
um
i love it yeah also it's fun just to
like
i mean it's fun to just tell everybody
like i tell
i tell anyone he's a firefighter i'm
like i'll be at cvs
and i'll be like they can take their
badge out they call it tinum
and i'd be like turtle you know like
he'll be like we're in a cvs they just
don't
have the kind of gum i'm looking for
it's not a tenem situation but i just
have fun with it you know
until uh a global pandemic kids
exactly yeah it's it's it's cool though
it's a cool world
and uh they're fun they're definitely a
fun group firefighters
i love it i love it well as a new mother
uh where can people find you on the
internet and
find me at rachel on instagram at rachel
feinstein
underscore and on is there that many
rachel feinstein's that you had to get
the underscore
you know this is going to sound like
such a name drop and it absolutely is
but
i did this show with shaq and shaq was
like not on instagram we used to do this
tv show that was canceled immediately
me and jack co-hosted it he's like you
gotta be on instagram
and so that was like not the best check
but um
he set it up for me he was like you need
to do it he just took my phone and
he did that and he put the underscore
because you couldn't just have your name
you gotta have an underscore
i guess so but i didn't set it up and uh
you you should just put it rachel
feinstein
underscore just put shaq's name in there
just give him some credit
all right so you're on instagram where
else uh you can go to my website
at rachel feinstein.com
and um oh i should let pete say hi he'll
be happy to meet you all right let's do
it
okay yes yes
so for those of you that are listening
and or watching rachel is going to get
her
uh her husband real quick uh i have no
clue
if he's inside the house outside the
house maybe he's at the fire station
we're gonna find out in a second
but she's now left she's going to get
him
maybe i can do like a filibuster like
they do on the uh
on the senate floor i think or the
congressional floor
see if we can find him he may refuse he
may say no
no he's coming on he's got that
he's just trying to press down his no
kobe haircut
yeah i've been coming here in months
where is he oh what's up man
listen i got one question sure sure
what's the best conspiracy theory you've
ever heard at the firehouse
oh
[Laughter]
by the way i said that it sounds like
it's just a bunch of bitcoiners from
twitter like just hanging out at the
firehouse
they read someone else's conspiracy like
that sounds good enough
my favorite thing is uh uh when you see
whether policemen firemen whatever you
know like i'm like what do you think the
two cops sitting in that car outside cvs
with their lights on and they're just
trying to deter people from stealing
[ __ ]
what are they talking about all day
because it's definitely it's definitely
stuff that the public doesn't want to
hear
i mean it's the same with the yeah when
you're in the fire you know the engine
or the truck
it's uh you're kind of you're up front
with the shoulder and there's the guys
hanging on the back of the cat
sometimes i can overhear their
conversation they just start something
like the most random stuff
all right guys you know it's just like
zone out forward
that's it that's how it is though you
know i i love it because of the distrust
of uh of the government of society etc
right we were talking about the
temperature gun right and it's like oh i
know that something's getting in my
brain with a temperature gun
that's what he said i was like that's
insane that's spoken like a true
libertarian they're
planting a chip in my brain when they
take my temperature
i i like the temperature i'm not sure
she loves all this stuff yeah
we disagree on when it comes to these
kind of things you know i'll take a
temperature
i feel like that's the next vaccine
first i don't know about the backseat
i'll take my time
i'll let her sit down see in a couple
years you know i feel like this is the
pi
the pilot that we need is like rachel's
like rational approach to the world
and you're taking the best conspiracy
theories for the firehouse
and just throwing her at her and letting
her react to them perfect
but he has been uh definitely uh he was
into bitcoin from the beginning
not to begin probably uh what was it
around
2013-ish 24th 14th guitar
it was a good time together who told you
about it
you know it's funny i just it like just
from the internet kind of thing or just
like i was
i kind of listen to some of the
libertarian podcasts and things like
that and they kind of started to mention
it
and i remember just seeing like these
articles like i get these rss feeds
and it would just like bitcoin it's ten
dollars bitcoin it's a hundred dollars
and then almost someone ate a hundred i
was like
all right what is this bitcoin thing i
started to read up on it upon it you
know
my only problem was then so on once i
really learned about my
stuff it sounds pretty amazing and
everything it just had so many great
fundamentals and principles to it i'm
like yeah definitely get involved with
it and uh
but now at this point the price went
from like 100 to like a thousand
and then it crashed down to like 800 or
whatever it was like 750 i'm like
all right it's dipping let's buy so
that's when i started buying and it
dipped all the way down to like 200 or
something i kind of just forgot about it
until your care 2017 is telling you
about it get out
yes yapping about it get out
listen but i bought at a bad time but
this
could be encouraging to people that
bought during the last bitcoin boom
and now things kind of looks like things
are starting to slowly rise now but this
could be like the next series for all
that and these guys could have similar
stories how
this is what i got him for christmas
because he said so much
when you're bastards yapping oh when
you're a barber when your barb is
yapping about it
get out that's true listen that's true
like once guys at the firehouse kitchen
start talking like the people that
aren't invested i'm just
like you'd ask me like you know because
one of the fundamentals about it what do
you know about it it was just purely
about
making money i'm like oh pizza piece is
definitely going to have
he's got like a activist short fund he's
just going to go around the firehouse
saying hey what are the hot stocks like
let's go short all those yeah
yeah that's it once once you hear the
firemen start thumbnails just like that
quote all right get out
that'll be the indicator it's like all
right let's take some money off the
table kind of thing
yeah yeah but i hear all this stuff all
the time money
is imaginary so i get little bits it's
true
that's a fact listen that i agree with
the conspiracy theorists of the world we
the reason why we all get along is
because we're probably more right than
wrong
right yeah sure there's a couple of ones
that we're not right about but if you
think about it like
it's probably more true than
it's not little bit little degree or
something right and the worst part the
worst part is i'm assuming
that uh if there's ever something that
comes out to prove one of them correct
it's game over because the next 100 of
them are for sure you know they're just
like that last one that was true
right it's like you give them a little
bit of confidence and they're like oh
god here we go
i don't know about i mean i don't
understand very much about money to be
fair so he's
that's not my territory he talks about
it and i well the dollars are fake and
the bitcoin is real that's all you got
to remember
okay that's what i'll remember i got it
poppy
you said that exact sentence to me by
the way many a time
congratulations again on your marriage
and are you gonna have before i go or do
you think you guys are gonna
create a human well uh now that i know
that the four-month-old can't go on a
swing
uh i'm prepared
that's a good lesson we were talking
about the uh
the rite of passage of getting the
carrier that goes in front like the
little backpack
thing where the baby goes in that's like
yeah that's like a big step right that's
like a
on my face you definitely have to
practice you make fun of me i'd practice
stuff beforehand
you would do drills you know every
fireman's got a bunker
by the way they've all got bunkers
you're you're laughing but if he but if
he put the child
in the backpack and and it fell you
would
you would have been horrified
[Laughter]
she was like with the packing plate
right he'd be like we gotta get the
packing plate down
get up in the morning we gotta figure
this out we gotta get it down
it was like always how can i put it up
and down in under 60 seconds i mean
there's a supply and demand
issue oh yeah the other
that's the other problem with cops
firemen soldiers etc it's like uh when i
went through basic training they gave us
a gun and they're like hey here's how
you take it apart like the m16
next thing you know literally within
like three days people are literally
having racists doing it blindfolded you
know with like one hand
and it's just like oh this is
competitive sure like i can i bet you i
can do it faster than you
so what's different with the uh the baby
equipment exactly
oh yeah who's putting their babies to
sleep the fastest
it's always a race
all right guys you would be you guys
would be good parents from what i know
you seem like a happy couple so uh
yeah we're just having fun whatever
we're like you guys make all the
mistakes and it will just be perfect
it's like yeah
i mean when you're ready we wait wait
until like the bottom of the ninth
yeah so take your time thank you so much
though thanks for having me
of course what uh tell me the website
one more time where people can go
in new jersey and listen to you or
actually just eat mozzarella sticks and
drink beer
it's uh hold on i'm just looking at it
right now it is
new brunswick n-e-w-b-r-u-n-s-w-i-c-k
dot stress factory dot com it's at 7 30
on
uh september the 30th uh doors open at
six well you know outside doors i don't
know what that means exactly but uh
six an hour and a half before the show
does seem kind of early um
just get there at 6 30. that should be
plenty of time get some food sit down
chill it's a good club the stress
factory like their outside situation i
here is very good like it's it's heated
it's
there's usually generally pretty full
crowds there and they have uh again
good mozzarella sticks so get it
all right guys thank you guys so much
for doing this thank you thank you so
much
bye